hey guys today we're going to answer the
question what is healthy about the heart
healthy Whole Grains now the American
Association of cereal chemists defined
these whole grains as any mixture of
bran andis perm and germ in proportions
one would expect to see in an intact
grain okay here's a picture of an intact
grain which is a seed of grass okay so
these are seeds that turn into grass
that turn into plants
that's what grains are and there's three
different parts you have the brand which
is the outer part which is the fiber
trace minerals some B vitamins then they
got the germ inside B vitamins vitamin E
trace minerals phytonutrients healthy
fats and then you have the endosperm
which is basically all the carbohydrate
a little bit of B vitamins okay so whole
grain is any mixture of bran endosperm
and germ in proportions one would expect
to see an intact grain okay so they
expanded the definition to include even
grinding it so we're not just talking
about an intact whole grain that you
would kind of soak and make some cereal
out of it's basically you can grind it
as long as you put it back together and
according to the FDA all you need is 51%
of these three elements together in
proportion to call it a whole grain okay
so it could actually include some
refined grains so what I want to
differentiate is when you go to the
grocery store very few people are buying
actual grains as a whole berry and
soaking them and eating them like that
great majority of people are buying them
already ground down and the problem that
when you grind these whole grains even
try to put them back together they're
still exposed to oxygen and oxygen is
what destroys vitamin E part of the beet
complex a lot of the phytonutrients a
lot of healthy fats so the more this
grain is exposed to air the more it'll
go rancid the more it'll be exposed to
mold and things like that so they have
to add chemicals to preserve it so it's
not going to be that preserved and not
to mention all the processing when they
puff
the grain or they flake it to make
cereals and the other real big problem
is that when you buy whole grains you're
not just buying whole grains a lot of
times we're adding tons of sugar
sweeteners chemicals on top of the whole
grains and because it says heart-healthy
you think oh wow this is really healthy
I can go ahead and eat it and when we
talk about refined grains refined grains
are basically you're removing the bran
and the germ okay it's only the
endosperm which is all the carbohydrate
and of course because there's not a lot
of vitamins in this they have to enrich
it with synthetic B vitamins and a toxic
metallic iron which is very toxic to
your body I did a video on that I'm
gonna put a link down below if you
haven't seen it so unless you're
consuming intact whole grains and you're
letting them soak and you're cooking
them correctly from my viewpoint it is
not very healthy and even intact whole
grains from my viewpoint is not good on
a ketogenic diet and whether something
is made with whole-grain flour or fine
grained it's still very high on the
glycemic index even higher than actual
sugar all right thanks for watching and
put your comments down below
hey guys a lot of you already have my
book some of you don't but this new
edition called the new body type guide
is an upgrade from my last Edition
called the seven principles of fat
burning it has a hundred and fifty six
images three hundred seventy eight pages
full glossary I talked about keto in a
minute fasting the body types in detail
I have a new stressed chapter I'm going
to show you exactly what to eat any
comprehensive FAQ I put a link down
below check it out